[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARL ROVE: Politics has
constantly been changing.
DAVID AXELROD:
It's exhilarating.
It can be exasperating.
Truth is that Karl and I don't
see eye to eye on some things.
We'll just keep
this between us,
but I actually like the guy.
There goes my career.
KARL ROVE: Reagan used to say
that our American democracy was
always one generation
away from extinction.
DAVID AXELROD: We're more
polarized now than ever.
That's understandable.
We're in a tribal moment.
DAVID AXELROD: In
a great campaign,
you have a very clear
sense of what it's about.
KARL ROVE: A lot of
the campaign is going
to depend upon the message.
Donald Trump was
the anti-Obama.
He held himself out as,
I'm going to take a brick
and throw it through
the plate glass window.
Mission accomplished.
If you're in a
campaign and you don't
believe you're going
to make a mistake,
you're in the wrong business.
The lesson is, when
you're attacked,
respond, impeach the charge, and
then go back on the offensive.
I have as much experience
as Jack Kennedy did.
Senator, you're
no Jack Kennedy.
[LAUGHTER]
KARL ROVE: Pow!
Right there.
These are battles
of definition.
KARL ROVE: Each
candidate's trying to say,
I'm the answer to your
question in this election.
DAVID AXELROD: Exactly.
It's a performance.
And look at the campaigns
in the 19th century.
And they were brutal.
They just weren't on television.
The one corrective in a
democracy is the vote.
Our moment is now.
KARL ROVE: If you've never
been involved in politics,
don't be afraid to get started.
DAVID AXELROD: It
is really important
to be agents of change.
KARL ROVE: Politics is a
wonderful, noble profession,
and it ought to be the passion
of every single American.
DAVID AXELROD: If you want
change, this is your choice.
Well said.
DAVID AXELROD:
I'm David Axelrod.
I'm Karl Rove.
BOTH: And this is
our MasterClass.